[Music]
foreign
so first to get started what's node.js
this is Lesson Zero of get programming
with node.js
so node just like many other platforms
and environments allow you to build an
application
specifically here with JavaScript and
what makes node so unique is that
JavaScript up until the last decade was
primarily used in the web browser so if
you think of Google Chrome Internet
Explorer Mozilla you're basically only
seeing JavaScript rendered on a web page
when you're clicking buttons when you're
seeing certain animations now that's
great and that really progressed the web
for us but ultimately
JavaScript as a language was much more
powerful than just its use on the
browser and ultimately people got
together and said we can actually
extract what Google Chrome put together
for us in Google Chrome's V8 engine
and use that outside of the browser
and actually be able to run JavaScript
through a node.js server so what that
basically means is we can build our own
apps without needing a web browser we
can build apps that don't necessarily
have a visual aspect to them and that's
what we're going to do today is build an
application that handles data transfer
but doesn't necessarily have a visual
aspect to it so this little this diagram
here was taken from my book and it's
very similar to the ones you might have
seen Elsewhere on the internet where
basically you'll see this single
threaded node event Loop and what this
is doing is it's basically demonstrating
how you'll have a various a number of
various tasks entering nodes event Loop
and this single thread which basically
means that you're not using a lot of
your computer's resources to handle
these tasks the single thread will Loop
it will just continuously be running for
as long as the node application is
running and handle various things like
timers specific task callbacks so if
you're basically saying I want to get
data from the database and you're
waiting for that data to come back
instead of holding up the whole
application you just wait for an event
to come into the queue saying that the
data has been fetched the process is
complete and you basically execute that
callback and you just keep going so in
this way
um nodes single threaded event Loop is
considered to be very fast a very
efficient way for handling requests into
your web server and in particular for
apis which we'll see in a second it's
great for building micro services for
communicating with a variety of
applications that are all interconnected
but have individual specific tasks so
first off if you are following along I'm
gonna recommend that you install node.js
you can do that by going to node.js.org
and downloading the long-term support
version which currently is 14.15.5 we
can take a look at that here
and you'll see the LTS version actually
just changed just in the last day but 14
16.0 you can just follow the regular
graphical user interface here for
installing node depending on what your
machine is
so it's pretty simple to install that
and ultimately once it is installed you
can verify that you have node on your
computer by opening a terminal window
which if you're not familiar with
terminal it will look like this
and um at least on Max you'll see it um
your computer is pre-installed with
terminal on Windows machines you might
have
um bash or command line either way there
are various ways to get to this type of
prompt and you can just type in node
dash of e to verify your version mine
currently is at 14.13.1
but any of these versions in recent
months will actually get the job done
for you and one extra tip here is once
you have node installed you can actually
just type node
and that will bring you into this little
environment which is where you can run
JavaScript so this is the simplest
version of seeing JavaScript run outside
of your browser using node.js it's a
prompt here with a little carrot and
I'll make this a little bigger here
where you can do anything that you might
normally do in JavaScript like
console log a message
there we go so we have the print message
there or to find a function so we can
say something like
let
add two numbers
maybe you take an X and Y
and then we can just return
the result of X Plus y for one doesn't
do much other than
give us the same
addition features that regular
arithmetic gives us but then we can just
say add
eight seven we can already see the
result preemptively printed there is 15.
so this is just normal JavaScript with a
new Arrow function syntax as of es6 and
we can run it here in our terminal
window so if that's new for you then I
recommend practicing in that environment
so next up we're going to look into apis
so what's an API application programming
interface and it's a way for for clients
individuals or machines to communicate
with an application server to get data
so how is this different from a normal
web server
um it's very similar um the only
difference is like I said earlier there
isn't necessarily a visual aspect to an
API in general an API will basically
return data to the person requesting
data which could be in the format of
HTML it could be in XML or Json or a
variety of different formats including
plain text so just like you might send a
text message with plain text you might
receive that from an application server
as well
and basically in summary it's a
structure to handle requests in specific
formats so this diagram below is also
from get programming with node.js and
it's a very simple diagram to show that
there's a two-way street between the
client and your server your server being
your computer or a some sort of
computing machine where your application
sits it will take in a request saying
from someone saying I want some sort of
data maybe it is an image sharing
application what you're saying I want to
see this image that is a request going
out to the server and the server will be
able to return that image back to you it
might be some form of text it might be a
book it could be a video stream and that
might be an ongoing connection where
you're getting fed every little bit of
video in that stream but still is
um a way in which the client can
communicate with the server and get data
back so it's pretty simple as far as
what that communication looks like it's
a request and a response so what do we
care about in the request so there's a
few things there's a few ways that you
can basically ask for data or modify
data
outside of video streams and open
connections there are a few basic ways
to communicate with a server and that is
through a
uh get method post patch put and delete
so these are a few different types of
request methods the most common one
you'll see is get which is basically
saying I want to see this data in some
form every time you go to a web page in
which you're not filling out a form
you're basically making a get request
however you can make a get request for
data and just get the data back without
actually seeing a whole web page being
rendered in front of you
post on the other hand is when you do
fill out a form or when you send data to
a server basically saying I want to
create a new user account or I want to
post a new some new content on a forum
you're creating a post request typically
in that case if you're trying to modify
data in a database you might be doing it
with a post request
patch input are a way to update data so
if you already have a user account and
you want to change your email address
typically you're using patch or put to
make that change in the database you'll
use your user ID as a way to identify
your data and then send some of the
additional data that you want to change
and of course delete destroy getting rid
of that data from the database you're
telling the server from a distance from
your phone from your computer I don't
want this database data to sit in the
database anymore let's delete it
so aside from the method we have two
other pretty important aspects of the
request one is the request headers
so you might have seen these before uh
before in different formats maybe you
try to hit
um a website and it was overloaded it
couldn't handle all the traffic and you
might have seen some content on the
screen saying request from this server
overloaded internal error or something
like that sometimes it just kind of like
displays all that information which
isn't great to see on a web page but
every every request has these headers
one um here are just two types of
headers that we might care about one is
the type of data that you accept
so
basically saying what is the format of
the data that you want to see could it
be XML Json HTML that's
a piece of metadata in the request in
which you're specifying what do I want
to say
and authorization now we'll get to this
again at the end of this session but
basically this is
formatting your credentials to say that
I am allowed to actually access this
data or see this data
um now you don't always need credentials
you don't always need authorization
um visiting a basic public website you
know need authorization
however accessing data from an API that
just be might be raw data typically you
do have some form of authorization
through an API key or through some sort
of token and we'll take a look at how we
can generate one ourselves and the last
thing is the payload so depending on
whether you're requesting data or you're
posting data you might have a payload
which is the data that you actually want
to send so when you're filling out a
form and you're saying my name is John
Wexler and here's my email address that
might go in the body of your request and
then it gets received by the server
where the server can then say okay let's
take this data from the body and save it
to the database so with every request we
typically have a response and a response
has a few pieces of information that we
care about as well one is the status
code what is the status of how that
server received your request did it was
it successful did we save the data so
typically you know this one we have 200
here for Success we have 400s and 500s
for certain types of errors and we'll
take a look at that as well later but
these are just different ways for
computers for browsers and servers to
communicate with one another over HTTP
to say something was successful or
something went wrong it's a great way
for debugging for tracking issues and
for just letting the user know when
something didn't work the way they
expected
and just like request headers we have
response headers metadata about the
server it might tell you what type of
server it's coming from maybe the IP
address location certain information
related to the company that maintains
that server that will go in the response
headers sometimes it's particularly
important for security reasons and we'll
take a look at what those response
headers look like as well and lastly
most responses have bought a body some
sort of data
um you're after all you're requesting
data or even if you're posting data you
want to know that it was successful so
typically a server will give you a
response body with some of that data
great so we have an example here but
before we get into it let's just take a
look at what a common request and
response
um
but the common request and response data
looks like so if I open up the network
tab here in Chrome
developer tools I'm just going to
looking at the node.js website and if I
refresh
we'll see there's a lot of requests
being made here
um externally so
we can click on any one of these
requests like the actual document here
that populates the page with lots of
data here so we can see that it's not
formatted but we have all the HTML here
in a simple preview but we can actually
look at the headers too the ones we
talked about
um the request URL what I was actually
looking for what kind of method so we
already saw earlier that we can make
post requests and get requests so this
one is a get request
additionally we got response headers
um whether this was cached
will tell us if this web page has been
accessed recently before and whether
we're getting it really quickly because
it was requested so so so recently that
we're actually getting a cash hit here
um we have a few other things here
content type text HTML so obviously
we're actually seeing a visual HTML page
here so we're seeing that in the
metadata as well and then the server is
from cloudflare so that's an interesting
fact you know maybe if one day the
node.js website goes down and we find
out that cloudflare also had lots of
issues we can actually draw that
connection and say you know maybe that's
part of the reason that we have a
problem here
so um that's a little bit of a demo an
example of um what the request and
response headers might look like so just
keep that in mind as you're building
this out that these details do matter
and they make a difference for how your
data is received so let's go back to
this example now so we're gonna take it
we're gonna work on the first exercise
here now with movie data from omdb so
the omdp API is something that's
publicly available and it's a way for us
to play around with a little bit of
movie data to test out how an API works
so I've already done this ahead of time
by
um creating my own account and setting
up an API key but it's pretty simple and
it's free they give you over a thousand
requests per day to make to omdb
and what we're going to do is we're
going to build a mini node application
that does not have a web page connected
to it so let's start by creating a new
directory called movie API
and before we get started I'm just going
to point you to my GitHub repo for this
session if you go to node underscore
Express underscore API underscore twitch
on my GitHub page you'll see Jonathan
Wexler with no space in between if you
search this on Google you should be able
to find this repo you can download the
code and follow along as well here
um you'll also find the PDF with all the
slides for this talk and all the
examples for the rest of the exercises
in this session but meanwhile I'm going
to jump back over to terminal and get
started with the movie data data API
example
so
I'm here in our project in the node API
twitch example and we see here that I
have the movie client directory and I
just numbered these just to kind of show
you the order of the session but let's
jump into that first movie client
example
so just like in my book we have a
starting and ending position for every
exercise the end directory here has
actually all the complete code so we're
not going to look at that just yet
but let's just go to start start is just
an empty folder so there's nothing in
here and we're going to start writing
the code for the start folder together
if you don't have a text editor I
recommend getting vs code it's pretty
simple to use and it's free and you can
load all the code for this exercise here
in vs code as you see on my screen
you'll see I have both folders for the
projects we're going to work on on if I
open up movie client and start we can
see
you know to start we don't have actually
anything here
so what I have on the slides here is I
say open create this new directory and
let's create a new file called index.js
a very common name for a starting point
for a Javascript file
except index.js great moving on we're
going to build our request
so
right out of the box node.js when you
download it comes with a bunch of things
and it comes with a few mini libraries
in separate modules which are basically
just packaged code that give you the
ability to
connect to the internet to process data
in certain ways without having to
download anything additional just you've
downloaded node and now you can actually
start using it and this is one way in
which you can use it the HTTP module and
what we're doing in this example is
we're going to import the HTTP module
I've set up another variable here with
my API key
and in a second we'll see why we're
using this query called hacker I'm
basically going to look into the omdb
database for any movies that have the
word hacker in it and then I have my URI
set up and we'll talk about breakdown of
a URI in a second too but
um basically what we have here is we're
hitting the omdb API and we're providing
our API key which is unique to every
user that gets approved by their site
and we're appending a query to the end
of that URL
and lastly we're going to run an HTTP
get request on this URI and then we're
going to look at the response and this
is one way in which we're going to get
data from the site so let's go ahead and
pull this into
Visual Studio
that did not format great so let's just
grab it here
great and what's nice are is these API
keys do expire every 24 hours so it kind
of prevents people from overusing them
but what's nice about this example is we
actually
um don't need to
do that much we're not actually
requesting that much data right now
so if I save this we can do a number of
things first thing is we can actually
hit this API
with our API key
right away without needing to actually
run any code with node so let's just go
back over here and run this up incorrect
IMDb ID all right so we might need to
create another
API key
let me show you how this works here
so I'm going to create my API key here
if you are not if you haven't done this
process yet I recommend doing it now
and I'll say demo node here and submit
oh okay so it's not
okay we can just do another one here and
we'll just
foreign
great so I'm getting a new API key now
okay so I'm going to add my new API key
here
okay and then let's just go back over
here and try that again
and let's just add in a query here so
just like we were saying before
search for hacker and there we go so we
have some data here so we can see that
the data is just coming from omdb and
it's searching our query for us so we
can see that there's a title of a bunch
of movies here with the word hacker in
it
um obviously the format here isn't great
but we can see that we made a search
query and we got the result back which
is great so maybe I want to take this
data and modify it in some way I don't
necessarily just want to see it on a web
browser
so let's go back over to our mini app
here so index.js we're basically saying
do the same thing that the browser did
and create a get request to the same
link
but this time let's accumulate all of
the data that we're getting back and
print it and this is something that is
unique to
how we're making this get request with
HTTP is we're getting chunks of data so
even if the data is really small
what we need to do is append each chunk
which is coming back as a string and
we're basically just building that up
and once we get our final our ending
response
I'm just going to print it to the screen
and parse it as Json so we saw that this
is a Json structure so we're going to
print that once we're
done collecting all the data
so now we have our index.js and I was
going to write node
index
and there we go so same data
a little more color to it a little more
structure and we can see that we have a
search request and we have a bunch of
results a movie called hacker from 2016
the hacker Wars of 2014
another hacker movie from 2019 kiddo the
hacker so clearly
um being a hacker is popular enough that
they'll create a movie about it
um so there's a lot we can do here we
see that just like in this Json
structure we can pick certain movies
like we can
Target this search term
um
and we can say something along the lines
of
once we have the data here let's look at
search
and then
let's take a look at the first one
let's just print that out
great so we got our first result so
maybe we just care about that one or
maybe we want to iterate through every
result and just look at the titles we
don't care about the ears so let's see
what we have in common between all these
titles so I might want to say
parse this Json
but then I'm going to map on each of
these
um
and say something along the lines of
item
cranks item dot name
and bring that back into our console log
oh title I think it was
actually let's take a look
here
foreign
title capitalized okay
let's try it again
great so now we just have a quick list
of all the titles we don't care about
all the other data but what's nice about
this is that the control is now in our
hands we can modify this data however we
like in particular